if you played in 2019 and also my
congratulations on your victory in
Dortmund you're just coming from this
event where castling was not possible
and I wonder if you have reached the
conclusion is it good to Castle or not
I think I think it's good to Castle I
wonder how it would uh how long I'd be
able to survive if I couldn't Castle but
my opponent could I think maybe not not
very long against good players it was
definitely a pretty big challenge to try
to adjust to that type of Chess so I
enjoyed it but you know I wouldn't want
to play it every single tournament so
I'm glad to be playing normal chess
again yeah but I think against whom in
this tournament do you think it would
work this kind of strategy without
Catholic well I Richie is playing right
exactly yeah that's what I thought the
reason I was thinking that was because
in in the candidates last year we played
a game uh where instead of castling I
moved my Rooks to F1 into D1 so it
looked like I was trying to Castle but
unable to figure out the rules where I
actually also move my king and I think
people uh kind of paid attention to that
and they almost called it like no
castling chess especially in the
candidates because it's not such a
serious tournament you don't expect to
see some kind of strange things but
during the game you don't even think
about it like you're just making your
moves and sometimes some unusual things
happen so maybe against Richie I think
that we would we would manage quite well
to find a way not to Castle even in
normal chess yeah I think so too because
I remembered that I was kind of checking
when will be this moment here with
castle in the games and normally it was
after move 15 then sometimes never
happened
no he's a very original player for sure
yeah and whom I also looking forward to
playing this event it's a different
field a little bit
um
yeah I think kukash is always very
interesting as a young player alireza of
course Magnus
um
I think against Magnus I haven't played
rapid and Blitz since the world
championship we played one Blitz game
one rapid game there okay we played a
lot of online but uh speaking strictly
about over the board chest since the
world championships and almadi we
haven't played uh any wrapped in Blitz
and we also avoided Armageddon in in
Norway so that'll be interesting uh and
you know I like to see the the young
guys because they're always changing in
terms of how they how they approached us
how they play and so it'll be
interesting to see how they perform and
um but I have to say all the players are
interesting you know it's it's not like
you have any
um any guys who are not fighting every
game here so so I think we have a good
mix of players yeah for sure and you won
the classical event in Romania and now
we're playing in rabbit and Blitz I was
wondering if you ever won any rabbit and
Blitz event on grantchester I mean do
you recall no I haven't I can say that
pretty pretty confidently uh the best
I've gotten was second place I think in
maybe more than once but I remember one
year Nakamura ran away with the
tournament in St Louis wrapping in Blitz
and St Louis I think it was 2021 but I
could could be mistaken but I think I'm
pretty sure it was 2021 and he was
dominating it and I was having a good
tournament but it was only enough for a
second
uh one of like my I felt it was kind of
unfair last year I was playing in Poland
and I scored plus 10. and I got fourth
place and I thought this was really not
fair at least like plus 10 you should
get like second place or something but
but everyone was playing really well
there that was that was the issue so
sometimes even if you're playing well
you still have to you have to play
better than your opponent so that's for
sure but does it bother you a little bit
you know the fact that you have never
won any rapid event I I would definitely
like to win I I have to say I in general
the grand just tour I haven't had the
best results for some reason
um over the years I think the best I did
was third place and and grantchester's
tour so I don't know why it is but I
haven't shown the consistency that some
other players have who are very
successful here like let's say Wesley
obviously Magnus Hikaru uh so I'm hoping
to improve this year
that's great and actually just pick a
grunts tour what do you think um
grantchester has what kind of impact has
on the history of Chess and that's in
your own career
yeah I think now we're starting to see
the kind of
Resurgence and popularity of these uh
these giant chess tours that start at
the beginning of the year and culminate
and the grandchester was the first to do
it I think 2015 was the first time uh
and it looked very different in terms of
the tournaments we were playing there
but the format was similar and then at
some point there was a Innovation to
have some sort of final like a final
four which was uh we played a few times
in London the
um some sort of knockout deal yeah many
matches and that was very interesting
too in fact I would I hope some at some
point to see a return to that because I
I like the idea of like a a final and
like final matches and uh some sort of
big
um you know culmination of the of the
event but I I think the idea of a tour a
grandchild's tour was uh was definitely
innovating and it's now we see that it's
a great format a lot of other organizers
are also trying it out yeah that's for
sure and about for you for yourself for
your chest development did it help for
you as a player did participate in all
these events no of course it's been
great to every year to have a series of
events that are super high level high
quality well organized uh I have to say
I don't know about like the development
of my child's because I was already kind
of a decent player when these this
grandchild store started but definitely
every year it's been great to come back
and to play these events yeah thank you
so much and all the best of luck for you
in this one like that group thank you
foreign
[Music]